I think it's at least 10 to 15 years
since I've seen this oh yeah easy I
think Xiao Zhao was on like albino black
sheep
oh wow I remember that yeah wow this
video doesn't get enough likes it's
gonna get blamed erased from the
internet
huge thanks to expressvpn for sponsoring
today's episode Stick Around to the end
to see how you can get three months free
hey what's up welcome back to another
episode of animators react we are joined
by a very special guest we got Aaron
Hansen on the show today how's it going
man hey man it's going all right how are
you I'm doing great now that you're here
even better oh come on man
stop well tell me a little bit about
yourself uh my name is Aaron I'm from a
show called Game Grumps I've been doing
for a while but before that I made
cartoons under the name Eagle Raptor
welcome
they don't even want to play the game
anymore
that's so stupid all right yeah this
cartoon was a big deal for me too
because I I was working a job I didn't
like and then uh Halo Reach came out and
I had oh I remember that yeah and I had
an idea for a cartoon and I had just
gotten like monetization turned on
because I was like kind of a rare thing
back then oh yeah um and then with the
release of this cartoon I had made more
money than I ever made in my life oh wow
and I was like I think I'm doing this
now but yeah like every frame in this
cartoon is just like completely off
model but that's what gives it style you
know that's what gives it personality
and character I love how they get all
like grotesque as they get stretched out
and you get like all the lines to imply
their like skin is wrinkling over and
folding I just wanted to go as hard as
I'd ever gone before with like the faces
and stuff because that was at the time
that was sort of like my thing was like
it was like the o face and stuff like I
had I had these like little moments and
other cartoons where like made like a
silly face and then drew it like really
detailed kind of like old like Ren and
Stimpy or SpongeBob or whatever dude
this is this is literally me I was at
the midnight release of Halo Reach I
bought the 360.
I bought the Xbox 360 and the legendary
edition I spent so much money that night
just to get Halo reach you know what's
funny never played Halo Reach
I swear so this is you right
it was my Facebook feed was just like
blowing only everyone was like dude I'm
in line dude I can't wait oh my God
Hillary I'm just gonna make a cartoon
about how excited they are
okay
I I made a lot of shorts mostly about
video games but also a couple other
comedy things yeah which era
specifically uh you know like uh pre
2010s so like the 2000 the odds yeah
yeah that was that was probably when I
was doing the most work all of my peers
were sort of getting into that world
through like newgrounds.com and like uh
they were using like macromedia flash as
like the primary yeah well like what's
really cool about that moment in time
though where like the accessibility of
like different art forms starts becoming
more readily available to people who
want to do it yeah it's this one sweet
spot in time where every teenager with a
computer gets to have that like epiphany
of like oh my gosh I can I can I can
animate stuff like on my own at home now
it's like I don't need a studio behind
me well it was also it also had a weird
vibe to it too because it still felt
super like underground flash for example
was very expensive right but but now
like so there's so many free programs
that you can can get that just let you
in like paint tool Sai I think just
added animation to it and I know
procreate I'm a big fan of using the
iPad and the apple pencil and procreate
now has like an animation or frame to
frame type thing onion skinning I I
don't I don't know what I would do if I
was like a you know a 16 year old and I
had those tools available to me probably
throw them away and play fortnite
time where it was like there wasn't any
social media it was just the only way
that you would get in touch with people
was like icq or MSN Messenger or aim and
everybody had all three just in case
yeah I remember those days I'm going to
get into this house this is my first
publicly consumable flash cartoon whose
Footprints are these what the [ __ ]
expect that
[Applause]
[Laughter]
yeah I mean it was bad on purpose like I
wasn't even gonna release this I just
wanted to make this to do the voices and
then I was going to just show it to my
friends on Newgrounds there's a system
called blaming when you submitted a
video there was a moment I want to say
like a day where it was sort of in limbo
and you didn't know if it was going to
like stay on the platform or not like
people would vote to see if he would
stay weird and if it got really really
downvoted it would get blamed so when I
released it I was like that for sure is
going to get Bland I'm not even gonna
check it and then the next day and I
went and looked at it was number one on
front page and I was like whoa and
everyone was like dude this is awesome
this is so funny man whoa and I was like
that's incredible and that was back
before there was no algorithm I can't
get around the idea of like uploading
something like this and be like well I
hope it gets to stay online
can you imagine if you upload a YouTube
video and it's like if this video
doesn't get enough likes it's gonna get
blamed and erased from the internet well
that was such a huge problem back then
because you know bandwidth is expensive
and if you were just [ __ ] posting
constant recently yeah like it would
take up so much of the bandwidth and
like you know it would just suck all the
life out of the website well I mean are
these smaller than video files yeah yeah
they're totally because it's all Vector
points and stuff you also got to
consider that this was a time when
people were still using dial-ups yeah
yeah yeah so
how cool is it that like so in this era
of just no bandwidth and super tiny file
sizes it's like yeah this is like the
one spot where you can actually have
something in pristine quality all this
stuff is vector-based animation so it's
infinitely scalable typically when we're
dealing with videos and photos we deal
with pixels you know you got a certain
number of pixels this way certain number
of pixels down and you get a whole grid
of that but with vectors all of the
imagery is made with math you know
equations essentially it's all happening
behind the scenes it's not like you're
writing out equations it's geometry
basically you ever played Tempest from
back in the day those old video games
where it was all like wireframes and
stuff those were vectors when I've seen
these in real life it's a bizarre
experience because it's like super sharp
super bright yeah and and like high
frame rate yeah because it's it's
drawing in real time basically if you're
if you're giving the the computer math
problems it's going to do it really
quickly even if you don't do digital art
you still use vectors every day like
anytime you type text that's fonts are
made out of vector images and so that's
how you can scale it up in your
Microsoft Word program and it's still
nice and crisp
I think Xiao Zhao was on like albino
black sheep
oh wow I remember that yeah wow what I
loved about that stick figure fighting
is that like the art style itself is
incredibly simple but that allows him to
mess around with the actual animation
and really get like physics in there
like if someone gets kicked they go
flying back and they instantly hit a
wall and they stop yeah you can feel it
you know what's what's weird about this
one too is they're using the line tool
to make these these frames right and it
seems almost like like it's like symbol
based anime like they're they're just
kind of moving the limbs as opposed to
just kind of like drawing each frame
individually when you say symbol what
specifically do you mean so what
everybody knows about animation it's
like you draw One frame next frame you
draw another frame right but symbol
based animation is like you have all
these pre-drawn things and they're
almost like like a little action figure
that you can just kind of pose and move
around a lot of shows do that now okay
um I mean that's like rigging a 3D model
to be animated exactly yeah so if this
is the 2D equivalent of that house
wait what yeah he's like recreating like
3D Guns I don't think this is 3D I think
this was still in Flash because this is
this is a thing that like Madness did as
well
I think it's at least 10 to 15 years
since I've seen this oh yeah easy so
this all of this is symbol based
animation there's okay I don't think
there's any frames that are hand-drawn
changes it's all just moving parts right
but like with their faces their faces
are like a little round so he would use
like the transform tool to like sort of
make it like it was 3D but it was just
the line transforming from here to here
right oh okay
very beginning oh wait this is how it
starts yeah I mean a guy doesn't like
someone else's music
and then he proceeds to kill like
thousands of people
it's like he's like in going through
like hospitals and offices and there's
like agent Smith's there
I don't think he's using any tweening
here I think this is all just moving the
symbols around frame by frame because
you can tell like an object like go from
here to here and then it'll invent the
frames to do that right right is that
what tweening is yeah yeah you would
draw the keyframe animations and then
the computer would just invent the
in-between frames so that would allow
you to be able to create more stuff
faster yeah pretty much it would be
really easy to tell honestly because I
think you could like if we just took
this into like after effects and point
tracked their head or something if it
wasn't a perfect art we would be able to
like actually look at the ark and and
figure that out the guy who just got
punched there like we see a rotation
click like imagine that like the
clicking of each frame there it doesn't
doesn't move in a super smooth Arc
whereas if we're looking at in between
frames here that were generated be
flawlessly perfect in terms of the Arc
In Motion right I mean granted it could
just be like a very small all tweens
that are happening here and there but
it's still a very high detail of of
Animation what I love about this is that
it's like a chance to be extremely
violent without actually feeling violent
and it was also the sort of thing that
you would never really see in cartoons
back in the day they're always like
family friendly yeah that was the whole
appeal of of the new grounds environment
and like you know albino black sheep and
like to a lesser extent e-bombs world
oh my god dude it was freaking Nostalgia
Lane here yeah
oh they're losing the keyframes the
hardest that was the pain sequence this
is what a flash looked like this was
like my life for like a decade you know
clearly this was like a screenshot and
they did it in Photoshop and then you
know when the explosion happened they
like had to edit it in Photoshop and
then bring it back in right so like they
weren't doing everything just in flash
there's a lot of like mixed media going
on here too and in Super Nintendo there
was a chip that you could put in your
cartridges it's called mode seven there
were different modes that was like an
upgrade to the graphics and mode 7 was
like Mario Kart where like the ground
was like a texture and then it would
like move around in a space right so
yeah anything that rotates like that
that's mode seven in in these days if
you wanted to animate something on a
console everything was tile based so all
the Sprites and everything moved around
on a tile set okay but mode seven
allowed the system to say hey I know
this is a tile set but also in real time
I can rotate it and redraw it every time
oh wow okay but that's what it reminds
me of in the animator versus animations
thing where if you took something from
Photoshop for example like like a JPEG
or whatever and then you made a symbol
out of it flash wasn't super great at
like interpolating the the the frames
for a while you can see like when the
the keyframes come out they look kind of
janky when they kind of curve and rotate
like the aliasing starts to kick in but
what makes this one work so well is just
how clever it is you know it's just a
it's a compilation of clever ideas it's
all good it's great
dang and the video just ends without any
you know hit like or subscribe you know
those are the days man yeah yeah those
were the days people just need to do it
yeah there's a call to action what does
that mean
anyway go ahead and subscribe to
Corridor Digital
uh
dude freaking Home Star Runner man
that's
I love holster well the reason I
recommended this one is because there's
a concept of being on model right so
like you have a model sheet and it's
like what the character looks like and
it's got to turn around and it shows
like the different Expressions yeah yeah
so like when you animate that character
that's what you use as a basis right so
when you do that you're keeping an on
model something like Mickey Mouse for
example which is a perfect example he is
always on model because his ears are
always facing the camera oh but like the
moment you turn them into like a 3D
model and he turns sideways you've never
actually seen a side view of Mickey
Mouse with his ears like flat yeah
exactly so whenever they make a 3D model
of Mickey they rotate the ears on his
head so that it's always facing the
camera oh that's right going off model
is when the face gets really distorted
or like the shapes are weird or you know
usually for comedic effect or for
movement or whatever but this cartoon
everything was off model and I thought
it was so funny because it's silly
looking you know this cartoon was hugely
influential for me to just be like you
know what screw it I'm just going to go
off model with everything
something I'm noticing here I've seen it
before in other like animations but you
have a static frame but all the line
work is still oh line boil it's that's
what that's what it's called yeah I was
noticing it too I have no idea what to
call it yeah man that was like that was
the hot trick when like we started
discovering that a lot of people would
do it and they would just draw the frame
twice and they would just Trace over it
and then you just ping pong back yeah
which is which is easy but what I did
there's a tool in Flash called like
optimize or something because it's a
vector-based system if you hand Drew
something you know there were a lot of
vector points yeah oh I think I know
where you're going but there was an
automatic optimized that would smooth
out the lines for you and it was never
like that great yeah but if you just did
it like five to ten percent it would
make it like just different enough in
quality that it looked like a different
drawing
um so that I would just cheat it that
way yeah
hey what are you doing over there I did
this thing that people called like
bounce animation I would draw a frame
and then I'd draw the next frame and
then I would just bounce into it with a
little like right squash yeah okay so it
gave it this sense of movement and
energy yeah but it wasn't I mean
literally just two frames so that bounce
you're actually distorting the frame and
animating that Distortion yeah even
though it's it's two frames that you
hand Drew each separately yeah and to
add more life you're now distorting at
Anatomy exactly yeah so it's like that's
the first frame and then I would do a
little like anticipation frame and then
like a little overshoot frame you know
there's a lot of people that would do it
lazy and they would just like you know
squash it vertically but I would try to
match the movement right so in that case
I like I kind of warped it a little bit
to the left because I was then it was
going this way and like squashing this
way and then kind of squashing back into
shape that was my version of trying to
follow the rules of Animation whilst
cutting as many corners as possible I
mean it works yeah so much of being an
independent animator or just like
working with a small team is is coming
up with shortcuts
[Music]
so this was probably my most recent
cartoon and I keyframed all of it but I
had a studio called yada do the
in-betweens and I think they did a lot
of the coloring too so you're saying you
would draw keyframes and that basically
just means you would draw the big shape
on this Frame and then by the end of the
sequence here's like the neck shape and
someone else will try to merge those two
together how many keyframes would you
have like on a per shot basis that was
way in between right there with the head
down and the Hand coming out so you drew
this pose and then you drew the pose
where he was down yeah the inbetweens
came to like Smooth that out yes how
much of your time does that still take
up are you still like deep in the
animation space right now or like more
like producing other projects
takes up at least yeah of your time
every week yeah I mean you know game
grumps animated we've produced hours of
animated content but we are pitching a
couple shows right now um I didn't
animate it but so it's still kind of in
the world but to be a cartoonist you
have to be a cartoonist like it takes so
much time to do anything in cartooning
do you guys remember the early days of
the internet I mean be honest with me
you might not and that's okay but if you
remember the internet used to be an open
plane of opportunity but courtesy of
today's sponsor expressvpn the dream is
still alive you can still access the
internet and not have your data stolen
by third-party advertisers or hackers or
sold without your permission I mean
isn't that wonderful just just think
about this they provide an additional
layer of encryption on your data as it's
out on the open internet so it's not
going to be taken by hackers or sold to
third parties without your permission
when you're out using public Wi-Fi but
also but you can tell websites that
you're accessing the internet from an
entirely different location meaning that
you can access TV shows and movies that
aren't available in your country or
region have you ever heard of this
little show called the office well guess
what that's not available on us Netflix
right now but if you tell Netflix that
you're accessing from Canada all of a
sudden it's available so look do we use
expressvpn all the time over here yes we
do because it gives us access to all
that content and it encrypts and
protects our data but listen you don't
have to take my word for it expressvpn
has been rated number one VPN service by
platforms like Forbes and tech radar fam
and I were joking about all the
different device types that can use
expressvpn and he made a joke about
accessing expressvpn from a smart fridge
and then they actually said
you prob you probably could try to get
it on your smart fridge too because
maybe you just want to have the office
plan every time you want to go get a
fresh fresh soda I don't know anyways if
you are interested in getting three
months free when you sign up that's
three months free just click the link in
the description below or go to
expressvpn.com Corridor crew for three
months free all right let's get back to
the episode huge thanks once again to
them for sponsoring this whole thing is
a jog down memory lane if there's any
awesome animations that you think we've
missed today let us know in the comments
below uh we would love to do more of
this this was a lot of fun I didn't
expect to have so much Nostalgia just
like injected into my brain today so
Aaron thank you so much for bringing
that for us yeah uh I know probably a
lot of you don't need to be told but
like where can we find you you can find
me at Game Grumps that's youtube.com
or on Twitter at Egoraptor isn't that
sweet how you have like a username that
you made when you're a teenager and then
it's like now your identity oh I mean I
can't get it anywhere anymore oh no like
I I literally have to be like the first
person on a social media platform well
at least you got on Twitter uh yeah I
did get it on Twitter that's that's
meaningful yeah anything else though
Tick Tock Instagram I don't I don't have
it yeah dang did you have a good time
yeah this is great I had a great time
sweet sweet blast